♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON GOT FIRED THIS
MORNING AS YOU NO DOUBT HAVE
HEARD.
IT'S A MAJOR PERSONNEL
CHANGE.
IT'S MORE THAN THAT IT'S
GREAT NEWS FOR AMERICA.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE LARGE
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
POINTLESS WARS IF BOLTON HAD
STAYED ON THE JOB.
THEY MAY NOT BE CELEBRATING
TONIGHT BUT THEY SHOULD BE.
INTERNATIONAL OIL PRICES BY
THE WAY ON THE INTERNATIONAL
MARKET DROPPED IMMEDIATELY
ON THE NEWS.
INVESTORS NEW
INVESTORS KEW
INVESTORS KNEW FOR CERTAIN
THAT BOLTON PLANNED ON
LAUNCHING ANOTHER MIDDLE
EASTERN CONFLICT THAT WOULD
SPIKE ENERGY PRICES.
SOME WERE DISAPPOINTED TO
SEE BOLT TO BE GO.
CERTAINLY MANY IN WASHINGTON
WITH DISAPPOINTED.
CHRIS MURPHY FROM
CONNECTICUT A PROGRESSIVE
ONE AT THAT QUOTED THAT HE
WAS QUOTE LEGITIMATELY
SHAKEN TO SEE JOHN BOLTON TO
LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
SAMANTHA POWERS, YOU
REMEMBER HER.
THE OBAMA OFFICIAL PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
CATASTROPHIC DESTRUCTION OF
LIBYA.
THE MOVE THAT FLOODED EUROPE
WITH REFUGEES.
THAT OFFICIAL, SAMANTHA
POWER TOLD REPORTERS TODAY
THAT THE FIRING WAS A VERY
TROUBLING SIGN BELIEVE IT OR
NOT A NUMBER OF OTHER
REPUBLICANS MADE SIMILAR
NOISES MITT ROMNEY QUOTE HE
WAS VERY, VERY UNHAPPY THAT
BOLTON WAS LEAVING.
HE WENT ON TO DESCRIBE THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR AS
A BRILLIANT MAN WITH DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IN FOREIGN
POLICY.
ROMNEY DIDN'T SAY MUCH ABOUT
THIS EXPERIENCE.
HE WASN'T SPECIFIC ABOUT IT.
WHY?
PROBABLY BECAUSE NONE OF
BOLTON'S EXPERIENCE IN THE
END HELPED AMERICA.
ROMNEY IS RIGHT.
BOLTON HAS, IN FACT, BEEN ON
THE SCENE FOR DECADES.
ALL OF US ARE SUFFERING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF IT.
BUT, WHATEVER.
THE DETAILS LIKE THAT MAKE
NO DIFFERENCE AT ALL IN
WASHINGTON.
IN WASHINGTON, NOBODY CARES
WHAT KIND OF JOB YOU DID.
ONLY THAT YOU DID THE JOB.
NOBODY THERE LEARNS FROM
MISTAKES BECAUSE MISTAKES
ARE NEVER EVEN ACKNOWLEDGED.
EVER.
JOHN BOLTON HIMSELF TOOK
THIS FORM OF SELECTIVE
AMNESIA TO AN ART FORM.
WATCH HIM PERFORM IT ON THIS
SHOW.
>> SO YOU'VE CALLED FOR
REGIME CHANGE IN IRAQ,
LIBYA, IRAN, AND SYRIA.
IN THE FIRST TWO COUNTRIES
WE HAVE HAD REGIME CHANGE
AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S BEEN, I
WOULD SAY A DISASTER.
>> NO, NO.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT AND.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T THINK
IT'S BEEN A DISASTER.
>> I THINK YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT LIFE IS
COMPLICATED IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
AND WHEN YOU SAY WELL THE
OVERTHROW OF SADDAM HUSSEIN
WAS A MISTAKE IS SIMPLISTIC.
>> Tucker: I WOULD ARGUE
THAT I'M THE ONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW COMPLICATED
IT IS.
THAT'S MY VIEW.
>> IT'S YOUR LONG EXPERIENCE
IN FOREIGN POLICY.
>> Tucker: BETTER RECORD
THAN YOURS, I WOULD SAY.
>> Tucker: DID YOU CATCH
THAT RATHER THAN JUSTIFY OR
IVAN EXPLAIN HIS OWN RECORD,
BOLTON BRAGS THAT HE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME ON THE JOB.
IF YOU ARE WONDERING WHY SO
MANY PROGRESSIVES ARE
MOURNING BOLTON'S FIRING
TONIGHT BOLTON HIMSELF
FUNDAMENTALLY WAS A MAN OF
THE LEFT.
THERE WAS NOT A HUMAN
PROBLEM JOHN BOLTON WASN'T
TOTALLY CONVINCED COULD BE
SOLVED WITH THE ELITE FORCE
OF GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S AN ASSUMPTION OF THE
LEFT.
NOT THE RIGHT.
DON'T LET THE MUSTACHE FOOL
YOU.
JOHN BOLTON WAS ONE OF THE
MOST PROGRESSIVE PEOPLE IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
BY THE WAY, NATURALLY ONCE
HE WAS A SCONS THERE BOLTON
PROMOTED OBAMA LOYALISTS
WITHIN THE SECURITY COUNCIL
THAT SHOULDN'T PRIZE YOU
EITHER.
FROM THE VERY FIRST DAY JOHN
BOLTON OPERATED AS IN FACT A
FIFTH COLUMN WITHIN THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
WE WARNED ABOUT HIM
FREQUENTLY ON THIS SHOW.
>> Tucker: WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CALLS FOR PEACE
WITH A HEAVILY ARMED NUCLEAR
POWER THAT IS CONSIDERED
TREASON.
BUT WITH THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR CALLS FOR,
YET, ANOTHER POINTLESS WAR,
THAT'S JUST ELITE CONSENSUS
AND IT'S FINE.
NIKON BOLTON HAS CALLED FOR
TOPPLING THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
TELLINGLY HE NEVER SUGGESTED
WHAT MIGHT REPLACE THE
IRANIAN GOVERNMENT ONCE IT'S
TOPPLED.
>> Tucker: TO THIS DAY MIKE
BOOT TAKES A.
JOHN BOLTON IS THIS
COUNTRY'S NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
THERE WERE NO CONSEQUENCES
TO THEIR FOOLISHNESS OR
DISHONESTY.
NONE.
YES, MR. PRESIDENT, JOHN
BOLTON DOES WANT TO GET YOU
INTO A WAR.
IT'S ALL HE WANTS IT'S WHAT
HE DREAMS ABOUT.
MANY WARS IF POSSIBLE.
IF YOU ARE NOT CAREFUL, HE
WILL DO IT.
>> Tucker: IN BETWEEN
ADMINISTRATION JOBS THERE
ARE CUSHY THINK TANK JOBS.
CABLE NEWS CONTRACTS.
WAR MAY BE DISASTER FOR
AMERICA BUT FOR JOHN BOLTON
AND HIS FELLOW NEOCONS, IT
IS ALWAYS GOOD BUSINESS.
>> Tucker: WE INVITED JOHN
BOLTON ON THIS SHOW TONIGHT
HE DID NOT RESPOND TO THE
INVITATION WHICH IS A SHAME.
IS HE ALWAYS WELCOME HERE.
THAT'S A SINCERE INVITATION.
IN SOME WAYS THE STORY ISN'T
SIMPLY ABOUT JOHN BOLTON.
IT'S ABOUT THE COUNTLESS
JOHN BOLTONS WHO CURRENTLY
THE STAFF FEDERAL
BUREAUCRACY DEEPLY MEDIOCRE
LIFERS, DRUNK ON UBEROUS.
PROTECTED BY BULLET PROOF
JOB SECURITY.
THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO DIE
ON THE JOB THAN BE FIRED AND
THEY KNOW IT.
AS A GROUP THESE PEOPLE HAVE
DONE AN AWFUL LOT TO MAKE
THIS COUNTRY POORER AND
SADDER AND MORE DIVIDED.
THE ACTUAL JOHN BOLTON IS
GONE, LIKELY FOREVER.
THE QUESTION TONIGHT IS WILL
HE BE REPLACED BY ANOTHER
JOHN BOLTON JUST LIKE HIM
AND UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
SIGNS THAT THAT'S POSSIBLE.
IN FACT, IN WASHINGTON, IT'S
ALWAYS POSSIBLE.
CHANGE ARE NOT ALWAYS FOR
THE BETTER.
DON'T LIE TO YOURSELF.
APPARENTLY ON THE SHORT LIST
TONIGHT TO REPLACE BOLTON IS
THE PRESIDENT'S SPECIAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR IRAN
BRIAN HOOK.
HE MAY BE A GOOD PERSON
UNAPOLOGETIC NEOCON.
HE HAS UNDISGUISED CONTEMPT
FOR DONALD TRUMP AS JOHN
BOLTON DID.
AND HE PARTICULARLY DISLIKES
THE PRESIDENT'S NATIONALIST
FOREIGN POLICY WHICH IS ONE
OF THE REASONS PEOPLE VOTED
FOR DONALD TRUMP IN 2016.
ONE ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
RECALLS HOOK ANNOUNCING
THAT, QUOTE:  I THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS RECKLESS AND
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND POLICY.
ANOTHER SOURCE HEARD HIM
DIRECTLY FOREIGN OFFICIALS
AT A CONFERENCE ABROAD.
A CHOICE LIKE THAT AND HOOK,
BY THE WAY, IS NOT THE ONLY
ONE, NOT EVEN CLOSE.
A CHOICE LIKE THAT IS REALLY
NO CHOICE AT ALL.
IT'S MORE JOHN BOLTON WITH
THE SAME PREDICTABLE
DISASTROUS RESULTS.